[Music]
aubrey is with us in phoenix hi aubry
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thanks so much for taking my call
sure how can we help um
i had a 19 year old daughter that has
had a lot of personality changes lately
um
we do we help her a lot she lives at
home
and we supply a lot of her finances
she does have a job we pay her cell
phone medical
expenses food car expenses school books
things like that
um she pays for some most of her auto
insurance and gas
she's had for like nine months they're
in love and infatuated with each other
she recently came home and said that she
was gonna go on a trip with him
out of state and stay in a hotel
together
we said absolutely not that's not okay
and not what we believe
and she has said well i'm an adult and i
get to make my own decision so we're
going to know
anthony told his dad that one time
you told your dad that one time what
happened when you told your dad that
i didn't come back home
you ended up living in your car living
in my car yeah
yeah it didn't go very well with us
either i said if that
is how it's gonna go there's gonna be
some significant changes
financially there's gonna be an address
change
yeah well i i guess that's why i'm
calling you
to gain your guidance of whether
we're on the right track so my thought
was
uh she needs to get a new cell phone
plan no
no longer piggybacking on us she needs
to find her own auto insurance
um she should move out she should move
out
yeah you don't stay under my roof unless
you go by my rules
yeah and new cell phone plan aubry
she's already making the money so that's
not she's not going to really feel that
pain
okay so she'll take over that right now
what i think and i'm not a father so
i'll let dave speak into this more often
but one thing i do appreciate about my
father
is he made it very clear you're going to
respect the rules
of this house the moment you break those
rules
you can go do you but you're going to do
you outside of my house
that's not mean why do you have that
belief because you believe it's what's
best for her
it's not affecting you if she sleeps
around
it's affecting her right
and you love her and you're smart enough
to know this is not a good plan
yeah and so you're just saying darling
this is not a good plan and
we love you too much to endorse your
stupidity
and let me tell you this much doing that
okay
when she turns 29 when she turns 35
she's gonna
really appreciate you for staying true
and helping her become
wiser because at the age of 36 my father
is my main guy because he kicked me out
of the house because i didn't want to
listen
that grew me up a lot quicker now
everything my father tells me
well i don't do 100 everything he tells
me but i sure do listen to his wisdom
and his guidance because my father i
know he loves me
and he wants the best for me but if you
keep letting her get away with these
kind of things
she's never going to grow and mature
into the woman that she can be
and by the way when she made this
announcement she knew it wasn't going to
go well
yeah yeah it wasn't like you just sprung
a new set of rules on her
she was raised a certain way and she
knew she was going perpendicular to that
right right yeah
so it's very very hard darling yeah very
very hard to set boundaries
it's very very hard to love people well
it's much easier to be a wuss
and just let people do whatever they
want to themselves
while you pay the bill it's easier in
the short term
in the long term their lives get
destroyed and so i'm not going to go
with it i'm gonna be the big girl the
big daddy the big mommy
and say sweetie can't live here if you
do that
you gotta move you gotta pay all your
own bills go be you
go back to that caller um sweet mom
is worried about her sweet daughter
who's wanting to run around do things
that the value system doesn't line up we
get a lot of these questions and you do
because you speak a lot on college
campuses
and a lot with moms and dads of teens
and of uh you know young adults uh
20 some early 20s that kind of thing so
you get this question a lot
i really do i i really do dave you know
here's one thing i go back to i go back
to the story
and you know the story of when my father
and my mother
i was a little kid and i used to always
touch the stove he's always touched the
stove
and my mom would always like protect me
from touching himself
well one day my father he saw me going
towards the stove to touch it
my mom was coming around the corner and
he said he told my mom no
he has to touch the stove my father went
and grabbed a thing of butter put the
butter in his hand
and then he followed me right to the
stove and as soon as i got real close
and i felt the heat i screamed
and he looked at me he put the butter on
my hands and he said you see why we tell
you not to touch the stove
to this day dave i wear gloves every
time i cook
because i am scared you still don't
touch the snow that's good that's good
i don't want to touch stove but the
thing is my father
he knew the only way anthony was going
to learn his lesson
is if we allowed him to get real close
to that heat he didn't let me touch it
but i got close enough to where i felt
the heat
and i think that parents sometimes
especially with this younger generation
they're scared to let them feel the heat
if they want to make the decision that's
going to impact their future
and when you're trying to tell them to
do something otherwise that will protect
their future
you need to let them feel the heat a
little bit yeah
but the discussion comes down to this is
not a bunch of rules
right that mom and dad put in place just
because we're cosmic killjoys
the bottom line is is that we got one
thing in mind here and that you're
you yeah and you're good and what's good
for you
if you are going to go against what we
value and what our principles are
you cannot stay under this house because
that is
us actually participating in you
harming yourself yes yes and so if i
give you a free place to stay while
you're doing cocaine
i'm participating in you harming
yourself i didn't buy the cocaine i
didn't say the cocaine was okay
i said don't do it don't do it don't do
it but you have a free place to live
because
i just i don't have the heart to throw
my own son out oh man listen and so he's
doing cocaine in your basement
or won't work and get a job or is doing
whatever other thing out there that's a
misbehavior that's bringing harm to him
right or her because you as the mom and
dad won't say
no no and and that's the thing you don't
have that's tough love
no that's just love no that's real love
because if you don't have the heart to
kick him out if he is doing cocaine for
an example
so are you saying you have the heart to
let him kill himself yeah
i mean exactly no no an enabler is
always
assisting people and harming themselves
so when you enable your daughter to do
to do things that you don't believe are
good for her you are assisting
in that yes and if you're financially
supporting her for one penny
in any way while she's doing all of that
then you are paying for
the behavior that's going to bring them
harm and that's not real love
it's not and so but i gotta tell you man
it's a tough thing because when a
19 year old bows up yeah they bow up
oh trust me i know i know you end up
homeless sleeping in your car how long
do you sleep in your car
six months yeah six months and i didn't
go back home
and it was hard for my father um and my
mother because my mom didn't know i was
homeless now my father knew but my mom
didn't know she thought i was
leaving with some friends but my father
knew the only way
this boy is going to become a man
is if i put him in that position but my
father
knew that eventually i would come back
home and he didn't allow me to come back
home until i
said i'm sorry and i'm ready to become a
young man
and i became the man i am today because
of what my father did yeah
because of that process yes and i've
seen you guys together for
the time you've been here you guys are
tight yes very very close
uh and so you know the story doesn't
always end up that way
it doesn't uh sometimes it's a
separation for life yeah
but uh but uh 19 year olds i mean not
all of them
but a percentage of them when they turn
that thing on and blow up
you just have to go as for me and my
house yes this is what we do
and it doesn't matter if you're 14 12
2 yeah or 29
my roof my rule right
this is not hard it's that's not being
mean it's not a dinosaur and i don't
really care about that dave i don't
listen to you for that
i'm 19 and i'm watching on youtube and
you need to go back to talking about
money no you just need to change
freaking channel because i'm gonna talk
about whatever i want to talk about
it's my freaking show the dave ramsey a
little twerk
and so that's how that works so i mean
seriously it's the same thing so
my house my rules yeah no you're right
you know and so
it's okay if you don't participate right
i can't make you do stuff you're a legal
adult but i can make you not be here
right i can i can make myself love you
so much
that i'm not going and this is the
conversation you have honey we love you
so much
that we can't we can't go along with
this yeah we love you too much
so we're gonna yeah we're gonna make a
federal case out of this yeah
yeah and by the way um
young man that's wanting to take her off
somewhere
dad be having a discussion with him so
yeah that see the conversation wouldn't
even got there because the father would
have got to him first
that can't be my daughter you going
where hold on a minute yeah go ahead and
talk to mom i'm gonna go to the store
real quick babe
i got some i got some stuff to take care
of here yeah
my you know my daughters were dad when
they were little kids you know dad all
the boys in the youth group are scared
of you
i said that's good yep it's good keeps
away two things you don't want
jerks yes and wimps yes no listen if
they're wimpy you don't want them and if
they're jerks and they got the wrong
idea you don't want them
so it keeps that away so i'm your
natural filter you ought to just say
thank you
yes you know and so then you know and we
used to say i got
great son's law i mean you know winston
you know bill yes i used to say i hit
the son-in-law lottery hit the
daughter-in-law lottery no i didn't i
taught them how to pick
and i showed them what dumb looks like
because i run off dumb a couple times
exactly
no dumb you know don't pull up in the
driveway be honking a horn unless you're
delivering a pizza buddy
you know that's not how this works so
this is my princess you're about to come
in here and have a discussion while i'm
cleaning my gun
oh man and so it changes the whole thing
you know i mean you got to set some
standards right
you really we joke around about all this
stuff but it's a
the process is love and then all of this
melds into the financial
because it always comes down to what am
i paying for dave you know some of the
millennials listening to you right now
thanking god that you don't have kids in
this generation they're thinking god i'm
not their daddy
that's what they're thinking out of but
yeah
i'm a dinosaur i understand i'm old
school but you know what there's more me
out there than people realize no for
real
they're everywhere all over america but
i have to say i've been guilty of just
pulling up on the outside i didn't
i didn't blow the horn but i did texas
i did texas hey i'm outside hey i'm
outside
yeah don't be texting either i'm just
saying
use your voice and your feet get up walk
in meet the dad
man meet the parents oh man that would
be scary boy that's good
on the first date he keeps you straight
man yeah well you need to get an uber
you know there's people tied to all this
you need to get him uber meet me at the
house meet me over here cause uh
i can't meet daddy's family it's family
family standing behind that girl i'm
just saying buddy that's how that works
it changes everything no it really
changes how their lives turn out when
they're 40.
yes sir and it changes the thing it
changes the process and none of us are
perfect at it
right and my daughters will tell you i
embarrassed them and all this and i did
yeah and i you know if i had to do over
probably be a little more gentle
yeah maybe now i'm kind of getting where
i don't give a rep i probably wouldn't
be gentle but
um i asked my dad would he if he if we
had to go back to that season would he
still kick me out he said yes the only
difference is i would have bought you
back in sooner
that's the only difference he said i
would have said all right you've been
out here for two months
three months come on back six months it
got kind of rough
between him and my mom when she did
eventually find out and so
he was like but no you had to go but i
would have changed that a little bit
just to bring you back in we would have
had a softness to it or a mercy to the
but still had the action
but i was the oldest so it was like he
didn't that
we all were learning at the time you
know so i think
my mistakes helped my younger brother uh
when he was going through his
rough season living in a car is not a
good idea
[Laughter]
well this all comes back to you know
this whole thing
of boundaries and boundaries are
intersected with the whole money
discussion over and over yes
so you don't have a right to your
parents money yeah
you don't have an entitlement to it
that's true you don't have an
entitlement to their inheritance
it's their choice